so of course we have to talk about the
Donald Trump bleach injection Fiasco
that over the weekend has turned from an
offhanded dumb comment into really a
catalyst of absolute international shame
which has pushed Donald Trump into
hiding over the weekend in the midst of
a global pandemic which he had
mismanaged from the get-go and is now
set to surpass this week the total
number of deaths that Donald Trump has
been predicting Donald Trump of course
talking about 60,000 coronavirus deaths
the United States already as of right
now at almost 56,000 and every
indication that we will surpass that
number this week and we have now this
unforced error once again of bleach
injections so please allow me some time
in today's show to really go through
some of the different elements of this
and to catch you up if you checked out
of the news altogether for the last 72
hours you may not have heard of this but
otherwise you probably know that Donald
Trump wondered aloud in this tone which
he has perfected which is a tone that
implies his ideas are absolute genius
and how has not how has nobody else
thought of this stuff Trump wondered
aloud what if we inject the disinfect
infections like bleach and isopropyl
alcohol which were the ones just
previously in the press briefing
mentioned and put up on screen what if
we introduced those into the body
through injection or some other means to
treat coronavirus now of course these
are toxic chemicals they have large
warning labels on them saying this this
can kill you don't drink this don't
ingest this in any way here's the source
of the insanity that kicked off the last
three or four days of madness we hit the
body with a tremendous whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and I think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're going to test it and
then I said supposing you brought the
light inside the body you can which you
can do either through the skin or in
some other way and I think you said
you're gonna test that too sounds
interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost of cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number of along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
but it sounds it sounds interesting to
me so we'll see but the whole concept of
the light the way it kills it in one
minute that's that's pretty powerful
absolute international embarrassment
will discuss that international global
shame momentarily shockingly or maybe
not from fists immediately started
falling over themselves to defend Donald
Trump some started saying he never said
it he simply never said it others
suggesting well it was a joke others
saying it was taken completely out of
context and unfortunately this is one of
those cases where the more context you
get the more clear it is that it was
accurately reported now there are people
saying that Trump could have simply met
different disinfectants like for example
he could have met medical grade
antivirals which disinfect the body or
whatever no here's a picture that was on
the screen moments before Trump used the
word it clearly says commonly available
disinfectants bleach and isopropyl
alcohol Trump turns around and talks
about the disinfectants you're talking
about putting them in the body instead
of using them to disinfect a desk for
example that's what he meant so of
course he said it now at one crazy
moment Donald Trump turns to dr. deborah
birx and asks her what about applying
heat and light to treat this dr. Burks
in the way only she can as an
unfortunately growing vector of
disinformation for Donald Trump she
bails Trump out by saying well there is
this thing called fever that's sort of
like heat in the body right check it out
I have to say covers a lot more
territory than just this this is this is
probably an easy thing relatively
speaking for you I would like you to
speak to the medical doctors to see if
there's any way that you can apply light
and heat to cure you know if you could
and maybe you can maybe you can't again
I say maybe you can maybe you can't I'm
not a doctor but I'm like a person that
has the food you know what ever have you
ever heard of that the heat and the
light relative to certain viruses yes
but relative to this virus that is a
treatment I mean certainly fever yeah is
a good thing when you have a fever it
helps your body responds but not as I've
not seen okay and then here is dr.
Stephen Hahn the FDA Commissioner having
to answer questions during an interview
with CNN's Anderson Cooper and dr.
Sanjay Gupta about this if you were
watching pay particularly close
attention to the expression the look on
dr. Sanjay Gupta's face as this insanity
is going on I will remind you this is
not a simulation this is not a drill
this is real life there is there any
evidence about taking a disinfectant
that's used you know on the table where
I'm sitting and using it internally that
doesn't seem like a good idea from my I
mean am I wrong yes I think it's an
excellent point you're making you you we
certainly wouldn't want as a physician
someone to take matters in their own
hands I think this is a something that a
patient would want to talk to their
physician about and and no I certainly
wouldn't recommend the internal
ingestion of a disinfectant again this
is a conversation that occurs every day
in America between a patient and doctor
Ivan in that position I'm sure dr. Gupta
has as well and it's really important
that we address them because people will
ask those questions of us well doctor I
just just I think we should be clear
though that the idea of doing some kind
of UV light therapy which is sometimes
used for local issues in the body but
not for a widespread viral infection and
the idea of injecting disinfectant I
mean the there's no those questions may
be getting asked but there's absolutely
no merit to that that doesn't need to be
studied you can already say that that
doesn't work right and I and I think
Sanjay that that that is exactly what a
patient would say to a doctor
and that would be the answer of the
medical experts to anybody who answered
that question right questions like
should I inject bleach our questions
really meant for doctor and patient
that's where those a thank you doctor
Han for clear clearing that up
absolutely shocking so the end result is
that Donald Trump during Friday's press
briefing the day after this took place
abruptly ended it and walked out without
answering a single question we learned
that right before the briefing Trump
staffers came out and they tried to
reposition CNN reporter Caitlin Collins
to the back of the room normally she
sits near the front clearly they were
expecting her to ask about this as she
should and the reporters agreed we
decide where we sit you don't decide
where it is that we sit and after they
refused to switch places after CNN
reporter Caitlin Collins refused to be
pushed to the back of the room Donald
Trump simply left without taking a
single question something he's not done
since the start of the press briefings
take a look I truly do believe the day
will soon come when we will heal our
land and we'll be able to reopen America
and put this great nation back to work
[Music]
so typically when Trump raps you get 30
minutes 60 minutes sometimes even more
of Trump answering questions
Trump instead just leaving now a couple
of other things we'll talk more about
Trump being and hiding momentarily but
Donald Trump has been hugely triggered
by all of this and we don't know what
the form or frequency of future
briefings will be one was scheduled for
today we don't know whether questions
will be taken we know that people around
from are telling him you're doing
yourself more harm than good with these
this is not good but in the meantime
notice the degree to which simply
quoting Trump verbatim triggers his
supporters over the weekend I got into a
crazy back-and-forth on Twitter with
Dilbert cartoonist Scott Adams who has
become a big vector of disinformation in
defense of Trump and he ended up angrily
blocking me you can look at look at the
Twitter history of it if it's
interesting to you but he was
increasingly triggered merely by people
telling him you're just denying what
Trump said here's the quote oh it's
missing context here's more context and
it is exactly as reported Trump
wondering aloud what if we take the
disinfectants you're talking about and
put them into the body let's next
discuss Donald Trump in hiding what if
you could read ten books in just one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink as' to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm do
really recommended blink east has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video